The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Back to
master equations
an optical Bloch equations.
I hope you remember
that on Monday we
derived, under very
general conditions,
how dissipation, relaxation
comes about in a quantum
system, namely because we
have a quantum system which
interacts with a reservoir.
The total system evolves, as
quantum mechanics tells us,
with a unitary time evolution.
When we derive life what
happens with the small system,
due to the coupling
with a bigger system,
there are now suddenly-- the
time evolution of the density
matrix has relaxation
terms, and we derived that.
And the special equation
we are interested
in for two level
system interacting
with the vacuum--
interacting with a vacuum
for spontaneous emission
are optical Bloch equations.
Today I want to discuss with you
some characteristic solutions
of the optical Bloch equations.
But before I do that, let
me first discuss with you
the assumptions we made to
derive a master equation.
And I hope you remember the Born
approximation and the Markov
approximation.
The Born approximation says
that the reservoir will never
change.
The reservoir is always, for
instance, in the vacuum state.
And the Markov
approximation said
that the correlations
in the reservoir
are delta function related.
It can absorb photons
instantaneously.
The vacuum has no memory time.
It's like a black hole.
It sucks up everything.
But it's always what it was
initially, namely the vacuum.
Do you know examples where those
assumptions are not fulfilled?
I make it so natural.
These are the most
natural assumptions,
but what are systems which
cannot be described with this
approach.
AUDIENCE: I was thinking maybe
like an atom in a cavity.
If you change the
vacuum somehow.
PROFESSOR: An atom in a cavity.
Very good.
If an atom emits--
now it depends.
We talk today about the master
equation for photons and atoms
in the cavity,
but we will assume
that the cavity
is rapidly damped.
If it's a high Q cavity,
the atom emits a photon,
but the cavity has memory.
It stores the photon, and after
one period of the vacuum Rabi
oscillation, the photon
goes back to the atom.
So the vacuum has memory time.
The vacuum has now
a time constant,
which is the same as the
time constant for the atom,
namely the period of
the Rabi oscillation.
Big violation of the
Markov approximation.
We do not have the very short
correlation time of the system.
We just integrate over in
the much longer time scale,
during which we are interested
in the dynamics of the system.
Maybe another example.
Actually, this example violates
both the Markov approximation,
also the Born approximation,
because the vacuum
has changed when
it has a photon.
Do you know an example
where maybe only
the Born approximation
is violated,
namely the reservoir is
changing due to interaction
with the system?
Well?
Before we talked about the
system in a big reservoir.
What happens when you make
the reservoir smaller?
Well then when it
absorbs energy.
It will heat up and such.
It will change.
The Born approximation
is actually,
when it would come to energy
transfer, the assumption
that the reservoir has an
infinite heat capacity.
It can just take
whatever the system wants
to deliver without changing,
for instance, it's temperature.
OK, so at least
you know now there
are systems for which
the treatment has
to be generalized, and you
understand maybe better
the nature of
approximations we have made.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Just a question.
For the last case which is where
the Born approximation is not
violated, is there
any example of that?
PROFESSOR: Well for instance,
spontaneous emission
into the vacuum, but
the speed of light
is so slow that it takes forever
for the photon to escape.
The Markov approximation
is more about the time
scale for the
reservoir to react.
And the Born approximation
is if the reservoir is really
big enough to simply absorb
everything without changing.
I don't know.
You could maybe think about
you have some reservoir,
but it has very bad heat
conduction or something.
The transport is just very
slow, and therefore you
do not have the hierarchy
of the two time scales.
OK, any other questions
about the master equation?
Optical Bloch equations?
Well, then we can
learn more about
the characteristic features
of the optical Bloch equations
by looking at solutions.
And I would like to discuss
three aspects of solution.
I want to discuss the spectrum
and the intensity of light
emitted by the atoms.
Secondly, we want to talk about
transient and steady state
solutions.
And finally, actually I put it
in the chapter of optical Bloch
equations, but I
will use a cavity
for that example,
which will actually
go beyond optical
Bloch equations.
It's also nice for
you to see that there
is more than the
optical Bloch equation,
but it's the same formalism.
And this is when we discuss the
damping of the damped vacuum
Rabi oscillations.
I also picked this
one example sort
of as an appetizer,
because I can introduce
two concepts for you
in this last example.
One is the quantum Zeno effect.
And the other one is the
adiabatic elimination
of coherences, which
plays a major role
in many, many
theoretical treatments.
But let's start with the first
part, namely the spectrum
and intensity of emitted light.
And I want to start off this
discussion with a clicker
question.
Do everybody take a
clicker out of the box?
So the situation is that
we have an atom which
is excited by laser light
of frequency omega L.
The atom has frequency omega 0.
I'm discussing the limit
of very low intensity.
And the question
for you is what is
the spectrum of the
emitted radiation?
So in other words,
we have our atom.
We have the laser
beam which comes here.
And now the atom emits
in all directions.
And you collect and
frequency analyze the light.
And I want to give you
four possibilities how
the spectrum of the emitted
light may look like.
Let's assume that on
the frequency axis
this is the laser frequency.
And this is the
frequency of the atom.
And the first possibility
is that we observed
a spectrum which is centered
at the atomic frequency where
the line meets gamma.
The second option is that
we observe a delta function,
a very sharp peak at
the frequency omega 0.
The third possibility is
the we observe a sharp peak
at the laser frequency.
And the fourth option is that
we observe radiation centered
at the laser frequency,
but with gamma.
So I would ask
you for your vote.
A, B, C, or D.
Was there any questions
about the choices?
40 for in spectra.
The low intensity limit
of light scattered
emitted by an atom which is
excited with a laser beam.
We can assume close
to resonance, but not
on resonance, so we can
distinguish between the laser
frequency and the
atomic frequency.
Anybody had a chance?
OK.
OK, good.
A, B, C, D.
Yes, let's discuss it.
I want to draw your attention
to one thing I said,
namely low intensity.
At low intensity, you can assume
that there's only one photon
scattered at a time, because
the intensity-- we work
in the limit of
infinitesimal intensity.
So I want to as you
now, why don't you
consider energy conservation and
think about the problem again?
OK, maybe I'm indicating I'm
not happy with the answer.
Maybe an obvious question
which sometimes people
get confused about, what
about Doppler shifts?
We assume the atom is infinitely
heavy and cannot move.
Or we trap it in an ion trap.
It's in the ground
state of the ion trap,
and no kinetic
energy is exchanged.
So don't get confused,
and I think none of you
got confused about Doppler
shifts in kinetic energy here.
We eliminate that.
OK.
Well it's moving in
the right direction.
Now the two most frequent
answers are those two.
OK, I've asked you to take
energy conservation really
seriously.
If you start with an
atom in the ground state,
and the monochromatic photon at
the laser frequency, and you've
done a wonderful job,
which many labs can do.
You've stabilized your laser
with a precision of 1 hertz.
And 1 Hertz, this is sort of
what I do as a delta function.
So if you take energy
conservation absolutely
seriously, the
photon, which can--
the atom is in the ground state
after it has scattered light,
so the energy of the
atom has not changed.
And you can only fulfill
energy conservation
if there is no change in
the spectrum of the light.
And that means delta function
in, delta function out.
Now I know I say it as if
it would be the simplest
thing in the world, but
maybe you have questions.
Does anybody want to
maybe argue or defend
why the light
should be broadened?
And actually discuss
very soon other examples.
We go to higher intensity,
and at higher intensity
other things end and
other things are possible.
But at the low
intensity limit, do
you have any
suggestion what could
cause the broadening of light?
AUDIENCE: I guess this is more
if [INAUDIBLE] but then look
at it as pinned down,
but you're going
to see a Doppler shift from the
recoil as the light comes out.
So it accepts the light,
and then it moves something,
so then it has some velocity.
And then when it
emits, it's going
to be emitting in
a random direction.
And so its final
velocity is going
to be in some basically
arbitrary direction,
because the two
[INAUDIBLE] boosts
that you get from
accepting and emitting.
PROFESSOR: OK now first of
all, I wanted for this problem
to assume that the mass
of the atom is infinite.
And at that point,
the recoil energy
has 1 over the mass term.
The recoil energy is 0
and we can neglect it.
So the limit I'm
talking about is sound.
But you're right.
If you want to bring in the
recoil energy, what would then
happen is if an atom
absorbs a photon
and emits it pretty much
in the same direction,
there is no momentum exchange.
Then it will be close
to the laser frequency.
But then you will find,
depending on the angle now,
there is a shift between
0 and 2 recoil energies.
If you would, however, measure
the light at a specific angle,
you would still find
a delta function,
but you would find it shifted.
But this is really
a complication
which involves now the
mechanical effect of light
and the recoil of a photon.
It doesn't change the result.
Energy conservation requires
the spectrum to be, so to speak,
a delta function
in total energy.
And what we have
just discussed is
that, depending on the
scattering angle, maybe
there's a kinetic
energy to consider.
So what else can
broaden the light?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Finite pulse time?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So things are very different
if I use a pulse laser.
But here I said the incident
light is monochromatic,
just one frequency.
And therefore you don't
have any time resolution
in the experiment.
The moment you have
time resolution,
you would introduce into
the whole discussion
Fourier [INAUDIBLE] and such.
But frankly, I ask this question
every time I teach the course.
And every time the vast
majority of the class
gives the wrong answer.
Let me ask you
something else which
is maybe a little bit simpler,
and that's the following.
You have a harmonic
oscillator which
has an eigen frequency omega 0.
You drive the
harmonic oscillator
at frequency omega L.
What is the oscillation
of the oscillator?
Is it omega 0, the harmonic
oscillator frequency?
Or omega L, the drive frequency?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Of course,
the drive frequency.
There may be a short
transient, but if we do not
switch on the drive suddenly,
we avoid the transient.
The steady state solution is
the harmonic oscillator always
oscillates at the
drive frequency.
Now, isn't the atom a
harmonic oscillator?
In 8421 we discuss the
oscillator strings.
We discuss that
the polarizability
of the atom, the dipole
moment, the AC stock shift
can really be regarded as an
oscillating dipole moment.
So the atom for that
purpose is nothing else
than a driven
harmonic oscillator.
And when you drive the
atom at a laser frequency,
the dipole moment oscillates
at which frequency?
The laser frequency.
Not the resonant frequency.
And therefore, the light
which is scattered--
think about it semi classically.
This is like an antenna.
It's an electron.
It's a charge.
It's a dipole moment
which oscillates
at the drive frequency.
And the light, which is emitted
by this accelerated charge
is at the drive frequency.
The atom is, for that
purpose, nothing else
than a driven
harmonic oscillator.
And I'm saying that
probably several times
in that course, when you
have a semi classical picture
and a fully quantum picture,
and they do not fully agree.
I've never gone wrong with
the semi classical picture.
But myself and
many of my students
have come to very wrong answers
by somehow holding on just
to the quantum
picture, and now seeing
what the semi
classical limit is.
You may think too
much here in the atom
not as a harmonic oscillator,
but a two level system.
The two level
system gets excited,
and then after it is excited, it
emits at the natural frequency.
But you've taken something
to seriously here.
It's a two level system, but you
cannot read the system that you
first populate a level,
and then you emit,
because the energy of the
laser is not exactly the energy
needed to populate the level.
So therefore you shouldn't do
first order perturbation theory
where you populate a level
and then you wait and wait
for the emitted photon.
This is light scattering.
It's a second order problem.
One photon in, one photon out.
And you have to conserve energy.
Sorry for hammering
on it, but it's
really an example
where you can maybe
realize certain
misconceptions, and I really
want to make sure that
you fully understand
what's going on
in this situation.
Questions?
Well, then let's make
it more interesting.
Let's introduce
higher intensity.
So let me first maybe
show you-- we've
talked a lot about
diagrams-- what
the diagram for this process is.
So we have the laser
frequency, and then we
have the photon emitted.
And of course, the length of
this vector, this frequency
is the same as the
laser frequency.
So let's move on now and
talk about higher intensity.
The high intensity
case we discuss
in great detail in 8421,
but you pretty much I think
know also from basic
quantum physics
what happens if you
take a two level system
and drive it strongly.
If you drive it
strongly, stronger
than spontaneous
emission, that means
there is a limit
where you can just
forget about spontaneous
emission in leading order,
and the system is nothing else
than a two level system coupled
by a strong monochromatic drive.
So I assume you've all
heard about this solution?
Get the Rabi oscillation between
ground and excited state.
So the high intensity
limit are Rabi oscillations
at the Rabi frequency.
So what happens now to the
spectrum of the emitted light
if you are in the
limit that you have
Rabi oscillation of
the atomic system?
And I want you to think
classically or semi
classically.
AUDIENCE: Three peaks.
PROFESSOR: Three peaks
you generate side bends.
Classically, you have an
emitter, an oscillating charge.
But now you want to throw
in that the atom goes
from the ground to
the excited state,
from the excited to
the ground state.
So, so to speak, when
it's in the ground state,
it cannot emit.
When it's in the excited
state, it can emit and such.
So you should think about
an oscillating dipole
which is now
intensity modulated.
And you know when you take
a classic light source which
is monochromatic, but put on top
of it an intensity modulation
at frequency omega Rabi,
the solution of that
are three peaks.
The carrier, which is the
laser frequency, plus two side
bends at omega Rabi.
So therefore, what we now
expect for the spectrum is we
have the laser
frequency, and this
is sort of our result
for low intensity.
However, when we-- in the
limit of strong drive,
and you will see in
a moment where strong
drive clearly comes in.
So if you have this modulation
at the Rabi frequency,
you obtain side bends
at the Rabi frequency.
And the fact that there is
a structure with three peaks
is actually the
famous Mollow triplet.
I know when I was
a graduate student
there was big excitement
because people measured
for the first time
the Mollow triplet.
You need high resolution
lasers and such,
and people were just
ready to measure that.
Now it seems something which we
just mention in basic courses
because it's such
a basic phenomenon.
OK, but let's work a
little bit more on that,
namely the Rabi frequency is
the Rabi frequency of the drive,
or you can say the
coupling matrix element.
But when we have a
detuning-- and this
is what you want
to discuss now--
you have to add the
detuning in quadrature.
So this is a frequency at
which the atomic population
oscillates, and it is
just semi classically
the modulation of the
atomic population which
creates the side bends.
Now if you take that to the
limit of large detuning,
or small drive, small Rabi
frequency, this becomes delta.
So that actually means if you
go to our stick diagram here,
the laser frequency is, of
course, detuned by delta
from the atomic frequency.
But the Rabi frequency is delta,
and this is the Rabi frequency.
Maybe some people who pressed
A and B feel now vindicated,
because now you have a component
of the emission spectrum, which
is at the atomic
resonance frequency.
And you have a
second peak, which
is omega 0 minus 2
delta or 2 omega Rabi.
Question.
How would you give
a simple answer
if I would ask you but what
about energy conservation?
I was hammering so much
on energy conservation.
How can we conserve energy
by have a laser photon
and emitting one at a
different frequency?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's
compensated with that.
And now let me ask
you another question.
If you would scatter n photons
and you do an experiment,
you would expect that, due to
Poisson fluctuation and such--
we've talked about fluctuations
of intensity and squeezed light
and all that.
But unless you do
something special,
you would expect if you excite
an atom it emits n photons.
You experiment.
You measure plus
minus square root
and you measure
Poisson in statistics.
But now let's
expect you observe n
plus photons on the
upper side bend.
And you measure and you observe
n minus photons on the lower
side bend.
Would you expect that
n plus and n minus both
have now Poisson
fluctuations, or would you
expect something else?
In other words, let
me be very specific,
if you count n plus-- we can
make it a clicker question.
So you have a
counting experiment,
and you have n plus photons
in the upper side bend and n
minus in the lower side bend.
And if you simply look
at the variance, which
is the square of the standard
deviation from n plus,
you find that it is
Poisson distributed.
So the question
which I have now is
what is the variance between
n plus minus n minus.
Is it simply the variance
of n plus plus the variance
of n minus?
The second answer I
want to give you is 0.
And the third answer
is something else.
So this is A. This
is B. And this is C.
Yes.
Energy conservation.
So there shouldn't
be any fluctuation.
The emission of the upper side
bend and the lower side bend
have to be correlated.
And you would immediately
verify that if I
show you what is the diagram.
We have ground
and excited state.
We excite with a laser
which has detuning.
But then we emit a photon
on the lower side bend.
The second laser photon
can now resonantly reach
the excited state.
And so you see we have absorbed
two photons from the laser
beam.
And what we have
emitted in this diagram
is one lower and
one upper side bend.
This is what happens
in second order-- well,
second order in the laser
beam, but fourth order
in the diagram.
We emit four photons.
And each time the
system does it,
goes through that,
it fulfills energy.
Or if I call the upper side
bend click and the lower side
bend clack.
The atom only makes click
clack click clack clack click
clack clack click clack.
It never does click
click clack clack.
It cannot do two clicks because
it has to fulfill this diagram,
and they always come in pair.
The two photons always
come correlated.
OK, so we understand
now the spectrum.
We understand when the
resonant photons emerge.
They emerge in
the high intensity
limit due to Rabi oscillations.
The question is now what is
the widths of those peaks?
And I'm want to short you
that too, because no you
realize some things are easy,
but other things are harder.
In order to get that, you have
to solve the optical Bloch
equations, but I want to show
you in the next half hour
how we can at least get the
salient features of this.
Colin, you have a question?
AUDIENCE: The picture you just
offered about the [INAUDIBLE].
That's assuming that
we're not depleting
the carrier [INAUDIBLE].
Because if we're
depleting the carrier,
wouldn't we expect
to see sort of
like a high order, almost
like a Bessel function.
PROFESSOR: All right.
OK, yes.
AUDIENCE: First order on
to the second [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, thanks for
bringing that to our attention.
There is an assumption.
When I said we
have a laser beam,
I assume we have
a laser beam which
delivers zillions of
photons in such a way
that depletion
doesn't play a role.
What that means technically
we replace a laser beam by a c
number, and a c
number never changes,
therefore cannot be depleted.
But if you would use a
very weak laser beam,
we have to modify the answer.
The extreme case would be if
we use single photon sources,
then of course we can
never scatter two photons
because there's only one
photon in the source.
But already if you would
have hundreds or photons
in your cavity and you
put in a single atom,
the scheduling of
single photons would not
cause major depletion effects.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: In regards to the semi
classical [? fabrication ?],
we said we have
a Rabi frequency,
and when it's excited
it's likely to emit,
and when it's in the ground
state it's not likely to emit.
So whatever frequency you
emit should be modulated
by your Rabi frequency,
but aren't you
most likely to emit when
you have a dipole moment?
Which would be in the
intermediate states between e
and g, in which case those
occur at twice the Rabi
frequencies I think.
PROFESSOR: OK, now
you go to subtleties
of a semi classical picture.
Number one is-- I just want
to say we're a little bit
dangerous, on
slippery slope here.
One is I really discuss
the spectrum here.
When I discuss the
spectrum, I don't
know when the photon is emitted.
So when I said we have
a Rabi oscillation,
I told you that the
system is modulated,
and this gives
rise to side bends.
But I can only spectrally
solve the side bends
if I fundamentally do not have
the time resolution to measure
when in the Rabi cycle
is the photon emitted.
The moment I would localize
when the photon is emitted,
whether the atom is in the
ground or in the excited state,
if I have a time resolution
better than the Rabi
oscillation, I do not have
the spectral resolution
to resolve the side bends.
So therefore the question
when the photon is emitted
is not compatible with
observing the spectrum.
The second question, I
think, can be addressed.
And that's the following.
I will show you in
the next 45 minutes
during this class
that the steady states
solution of the
optical Bloch equations
give us a rate of
photon scattering
which is simply gamma times
the excited state fraction.
So I think from that I would
say the more you have atoms
in the excited state, the
larger is the scattering rate.
So therefore, the
semi classical picture
that you have only a dipole
moment when you are halfway
between ground and excited
state is overly simplistic here.
Also, I just want to give
you one word of warning.
It's really an
important comment.
And this is the following.
The oscillating dipole
moment is a picture
which uses sort of the
analogy with the atom
and the harmonic oscillator.
And I mean yeah,
I really sort of
was a bit provocative
a few minutes ago when
I said just regard the atom
as a harmonic oscillator.
But you have to be careful.
There is one fundamental
limit between-- one
fundamental difference between
the harmonic oscillator
and a two level atom.
And the fact is the following.
This is a two level atom, and
this is a harmonic oscillator.
So the difference
is the following.
An harmonic oscillator
can be excited.
You can pump more and
more energy in it.
You can go to larger
amplitude coherent states,
and there is no non linearity.
The atom saturates.
And this is the difference.
Saturation.
When saturation comes, when you
put more than a few percent,
let's say 50%, into
the excited state,
you have to be very,
very, very careful
with analogies with the
harmonic oscillator.
So if you have most of the
population in the ground
state, a little bit here,
and almost nothing here,
then we can describe the atom
as an harmonic oscillator.
And everything you glean
from the model of an electron
tethered with a spring is
not only qualitatively,
it's quantitatively
correct if you
throw in the oscillator
strength of the atom.
But the moment you pile
up more population here,
and you just ask
about 50-50, at least
I would say
immediately be careful.
Do not take the harmonic
oscillator fully seriously
at this point, because there's
a fundamental difference.
In the harmonic oscillator,
when you're 50% here,
you would have
things over there.
The harmonic oscillator
stays linear.
But the two level system
starts to saturate.
Good.
So the question is now we
understand the stick diagram
of the Mollow
triplet that we have
always a line at the carrier.
Let me just put marks here.
We have the carrier and
the resonance frequency,
but the question is now what
is the width of the spectrum.
The general answer
is rather difficult,
but let me give it to you.
And I will derive it from
the optical Bloch equation.
Let me discuss that one
limit where the detuning is
larger than anything else.
And the other case
is the resonant case.
In general we
started out by saying
we have a delta function
at low intensity.
If you now go to higher
and higher intensity,
you still sort of have the delta
function from the lowest order
diagram, but the higher order
diagram become more important.
And the spectrum is in
general a superposition
of three broadened peaks
and the delta function.
At low intensity, you only
have the delta function.
At high intensity, the
weight of the elastic scatter
the delta function goes to 0.
And now let's
discuss the widths.
And that shows you that even
light scattering by a two level
system, those very, very
simple Jaynes Cummings model
has interesting and maybe
non intuitive aspect.
The side bends have
a width of gamma.
The carrier has a
width of 2 gamma.
But when you are on resonance,
the situation changes.
The carrier has now a width
of gamma and side bends
have a width of 3/2 gamma.
But if you look at it, the
sum of the three widths
is always 4 gamma.
And you will understand
that in a few minutes.
OK, so this was more
qualitative discussion.
Let's now work
more quantitatively
and describe the Mollow triplet.
The Hamiltonian for our system
is the atomic Hamiltonian
times the the z Pauli matrix.
The z Pauli matrix
is excited excited
minus ground ground state.
And because of the
conservation of probability,
it's 2 times the excited.
Also just mathematically
it's just that.
We have the three
Hamiltonian of the radiation
field, which is a dagger a.
And then we have the coupling
of a two level system, which
is the product of the
atomic dipole moment written
as sigma plus plus sigma minus
raising and lowering operator.
Just to remind us,
sigma plus is e g.
And sigma minus is g e.
And then we have to multiply
with a plus a dagger.
If you want, the atomic
part is the dipole moment,
and this is the electric field
both written as operators.
So this is the electric field.
And if you look at
the coupling term--
we've discussed it before.
You have four terms.
But in the rotating
wave approximation,
which we want to use
here, we keep only
the two resonant
terms, which is when
we raise an excitation
in the atom,
we lose an excitation
in the light field.
Or if you go from the
excited to the ground state,
we emit a photon.
So we have two terms which
form the rotating wave
approximation.
The other two terms
are highly of resonant
and can often be neglected.
So this rotating
wave approximation
becomes of course the
better, the more we
go in resonant, because in
one term is fully resonant
and the other one is
very off resonant.
And in this case, we can
simplify the Hamiltonian
because the number of
excitations is conserved.
The number of
excitations is the number
of excitations in
the photon field
plus the number
of excited atoms.
So this is the
operator which measures
the number of excitations.
If in a [INAUDIBLE]
counter rotating term,
this operator is conserved.
So if I introduce as
usual the detuning--
this is what my notes say.
It seems to have
the opposite sign.
I'm not sure if I made a
sign error here or later,
or if I changed the definition.
Let's just move on and
see how it works out.
So if you now do the
rotating wave approximation,
our Hamiltonian has now-- by
introducing the operator N,
the number of [INAUDIBLE]
times h bar omega.
However, we have
multiplied the N operator
with the photon energy.
If the energy is in
the atom, we have
made a mistake, which is
delta, and we correct that
by using the z Pauli matrix.
And then our interaction
term is a dagger times sigma
minus plus a times sigma plus.
Let's now discuss
what are the eigen
states of this Hamiltonian
In the simple case
when the detuning is 0.
And we have sort of two
levels of eigen state.
One is the ground
state with n photons.
And one is the excited
0, 1, 2.
So we can label this
by the photon number.
And the excited state
of course starts
with a higher
energy for 0 photon.
This is the energy
with one photon.
And in the case of 0 detuning,
the two letters are degenerate.
And if we introduce the
interaction, if g is now non 0,
the levels split.
And the splitting is given by g.
There's a factor of two.
But now if you have
photons in the field,
a dagger acting on the photon
field gives n plus one.
So therefore for one photon
we have square root 2.
In general, we get an expression
which is square root n plus 1.
Or to write it
mathematically, if we
have strong mixing
between an excited
state with n atoms--
with n photons.
And a ground state with n plus
1 photons, for the case of delta
equals 0, it's just plus minus.
You metric as a metric
contribution times 1
over square root 2.
And these are now with the
states we label plus minus.
The upper and lower
state of each manifold.
And n is the photon number
in the excited state.
n plus 1 is the photon
number in the ground state.
And the energy of those states
is the number of [INAUDIBLE] n
plus 1.
But then we have the
resonant splitting g.
And because of the matrix
element of a and a dagger,
we get square root n plus 1.
Now if you use
very strong drive--
and this addresses Colin's
question about depletion--
we use a laser beam, which is
described by a Rabi frequency.
This is proportional
to the electric field.
So be introduce
the Rabi frequency,
which is given by that.
And the laser beam
has so many photons
that we don't care about n plus
1 or scattering a few photons,
so we simply replace n n plus 1
n minus 1, whatever contains n,
by the z number, which is the
Rabi frequency of the laser
beam.
So this eventually means
that we have too many folds.
Plus, minus.
So we have two
states plus minus,
and they are periodic when we
add one photon to the field.
Periodic in n.
The splitting is the Rabi
frequency defined above.
And now we realize that when
we have spontaneous emission
between the manifold for n
minus 1 and the manifold n,
we have two possibilities.
To emit light on resonance.
And we have then one possibility
to emit an upper side bend.
And one possibility to
emit the lower side bend.
So what is called
the dressed atom
picture is nothing else than
the solution of an atom driven
by a strong monochromatic field.
The atom is dressed
with photons,
and the eigen states are
no longer just atomic eigen
states.
These are dressed eigenstates
of the combined atomic system
plus laser field.
So this dressed atom picture
explains the Mollow triplet.
And you can immediately
generalize it
if you want to
arbitrarily tuning
when the superposition
states plus minus do not
have equal weight.
But it's what you've
seen a million times,
the diagonalization of
a two by two matrix.
Colin?
AUDIENCE: How does this
explain the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It does not.
This is what I
just wanted to say.
It explains the Mollow triplet,
but not the line widths.
The line widths cannot be
obtained perturbatively.
So for that we have to discuss
now the Bloch vector, which
is a solution of the
optical Bloch equation.
So now I'm going to explain
you not all glorious details,
but the salient feature
of the line bits.
So the density matrix
for two level atom
can be written as-- let
me back up a moment.
The density matrix has
four matrix elements.
But if the sum of the
diagonal matrix element
is one conservation
of probability,
we have actually three
independent matrix elements.
And those three
independent matrix elements
can be parametrized by what
is called the Bloch vector.
A lot of you have seen it.
We also discuss it in
great detail in 8421.
But I'm giving you
the definition.
And sigma is the vector
of Pauli matrices.
To be specific, the three
components of the Bloch vector
are as follows.
The z comportment
measures, you can say,
the population inversion.
The difference between ground
and excited state population.
And the x and y component
measure the coherencies.
Either the sum of
the coherencies
or the difference
of the coherencies.
And here is minus
imaginary unit.
If you replace the density
matrix or the matrix elements
sigma ee, or ee,
or gg by definition
the optical Bloch equation
turns into differential
equation for r.
It's now a differential
And let me just write it down.
Let me just write down
the Hamiltonian part.
This is the equation of
motion for the density matrix.
I will add on in a minute
the relaxation part
which comes from
the master equation.
This is just the
Hamiltonian part.
And this would result
into an equation
of motion for the
Bloch vector, which
has delta here minus
delta here minus g.
g and the rest of the
matrix elements is 0.
The Hamiltonian, using
rotation matrices,
can be written by
a z rotation matrix
plus g times the x rotation.
And if you actually look at the
solution-- it's not a finite.
It's an infinitesimal rotation.
This matrix tells you that the
detuning does a z rotation,
and the drive is responsible
for an x rotation.
Let me tell you what happens.
You have seen the Bloch
vector many cases.
If you don't drive the
system, the Bloch vector
in the ground state is down.
In the upper state it's up.
If it's in between-- that's
where Timo's dipole moment
comes in-- we have
a superposition
of ground and excited state.
And it rotates at the
atomic frequency omega 0.
But we are in the rotating
frame of the laser at omega,
so in the rotating frame, when
the frame rotates with omega.
And omega 0 rotation becomes
the rotation with delta.
So therefore, the free
evolution of the atom
is based on this Hamiltonian
that the Bloch vector rotates
with delta in the rotating
frame of the laser.
And it's a rotation
around the z-axis.
If you drive the system now,
we take the Bloch vector
from ground to excited,
there are Rabi oscillations.
And this is now a rotation
around the x-axis.
Well, whether it's x or y
is a convention of notation,
and I've defined it such
that the driven system is
an x rotation.
The free evolution
is a z rotation.
And that's all you have to know.
This is the most
general solution
of two level system
without dissipation
that we have two
rotation angles.
One is the free rotation,
which is the detuning.
It is the z-axis.
And the driven system
rotates around the x-axis.
But now this is well known.
This is boring.
But now we want to add what
the master equation gives us.
And the master equation uses
as its [? limb ?] platform
where we have the sigma
plus jump operator.
And I told you that we have
to use the following form.
We'll hear more about
it, probably not today,
but on Friday.
You know that this gives
simply the optical--
this gives us simply the
optical Bloch equations.
We discussed it on Monday that
we have now a damping gamma
term for the population.
An excited state population
decays with a rate of gamma.
And the coherences, the off
diagonal matrix elements,
decay with a rate
of gamma over 2,
and we spent a long time
discussing this vector of 2.
So this would mean now that the
equation for the Bloch vector
has gamma 2 terms, which
comes from the dampening
of the coherences.
And it has gamma, which is
the damping of the population.
Well if that would be all,
everything is damped to 0,
but everything is in the end
leads to the ground state
population.
So we have to add this term.
It's just a different way of
the optical Bloch equations.
We have discussed
in great lengths
this form of the
optical Bloch equations.
And the sigma plus sigma minus
is because these are just
simple matrices with
one matrix element.
You've seen the optical
Bloch equation, I think.
We did also that
in 8421 21 that you
have the derivative
of the density matrix
includes now damping of the
off diagonal matrix elements
by gamma over 2 damping by
the diagonal matrix elements
by gamma.
If you simply substitute the r
vector for the matrix element,
you get this
equation in one step.
These are now the
optical Bloch equations
written as a differential
equation for the Bloch vector.
OK, sorry if that was confusing,
but it's simple definition
substitution no brainer.
These are the optical
Bloch equations
written in terms
of the Bloch vector
and no longer in terms
of the density matrix.
And questions about that?
OK, because now I want
to draw conclusions.
Our goal is to understand
the spectrum and the line
widths of the Mollow triplet
of the emitted light.
So I have to make
the connection.
How do I make the connection
from the Bloch vector
to emitted light?
Well, it's done by
the dipole moment,
because it is the
oscillating dipole which
is responsible for emitting
and scattering light.
The dipole moment
can of course be
obtained from the solution
of the optical Bloch
equation for the density matrix.
It is the trace of
the density matrix
times the operator
we are interested in.
And this involves the
matrix element dge.
The dipole moment has
only matrix elements
between excited
and ground state.
And ground and excited state.
Trace rho other parentheses.
So this is the matrix element.
Let me now write down
the density matrix
in its matrix element
rho ge plus rho eg.
But now we want to
go from the rotating
frame back to the lab frame.
And the rotating frame
rotates at omega.
So now I have to put back
e to the i omega t and e
to the minus i omega t.
This is sort of going back from
the rotating frame to the lab
frame.
And the picture
of we want to use
is-- the intuitive picture
is to use the Bloch vector.
So I'm expressing now
those matrix elements
by the component x and
y of the Bloch vector.
And since the x and y component
was the sum or difference
of diagram matrix element of
the density the coherences.
I get now cosine omega
t and sine omega t.
So that tells us that one
component is in phase--
well in phase means with respect
to the driving field we assume
that the system is
driven by classical field
e0 cosine omega t.
And now we find that the
oscillating dipole moment,
it's a driven
harmonic oscillator.
And there is a part which is
driven in phase with the drive
field, and one which
is in quadrature.
So we have those two components.
And the fact is
now the following.
If you have an
oscillating dipole,
this gives rise to immediate--
or more accurately,
I should say scattered light.
Remember, if you assume there
is photon first emitted and then
a resonant photon absorbed,
this picture is wrong.
You should rather think
of scattering light,
but the light scattering is
induced by the oscillating
dipole.
And what happens
now is-- and this
is why the Bloch vector
and the Bloch sphere
is such a wonderful picture.
The dipole moment are
the transverse component
of the Bloch vector.
So therefore, you can
say that if you're
interested in the spectrum of
the emitted light, what you
should find out is what
is the spectrum of r.
Let me back up one step.
If you want to get the
spectrum of the emitted light
from first principles-- I'm
cheating a little bit here.
I'm saying let's get it
from the dipole moment.
You should actually get it
from the correlation function
of the dipole moment.
It's sort of the two time
correlation function.
But you can show-- and this
takes another 10, 20, 30
pages in API.
The temporal correlation
function of the dipole moment
fulfils the same differential
equation as the Bloch vector.
So I've given you here
sort of the intuitive link
that would oscillates is the
Bloch vector it emits it.
But technically,
because you may not
control the phase of each
atom, you should rather
say the spectrum
is a correlation
function of the
dipole, and we should
look at the spectrum of
the correlation function.
But instead, I'm looking
now at the spectrum
of the optical Bloch vector.
And you can show mathematically
exactly that they
obey the same
differential equation,
but it's a little bit
tedious to do that.
OK, so therefore if you take
this little inaccuracy--
forgive me this inaccuracy.
Once we know what
the optical Bloch
vector is doing spectrally,
we know the spectrum
of the emitted light.
And for that, for the
optical Bloch vector,
we simply look at
this matrix, and we
ask what are the
eigenvalues of this matrix?
This matrix has three by three
matrices, three eigenvalues.
The real part of
those eigenvalues
gives us the position
of the Mollow triplet.
And the imaginary part gives
us the widths of those peaks.
So if you look at
this matrix-- and I'm
not doing the
complicated cases here.
If you look at this matrix for
delta equals 0 and g equals 0.
Well it is already
in diagonal form,
so it has three
imaginary eigenvalues
minus gamma over 2 minus
gamma 2 minus gamma.
So this matrix has three
complex eigenvalues.
And I want to discuss two cases.
For this case we have
minus gamma over 2
for the x and y component
of the optical Bloch vector.
And the z component
is minus gamma.
And this is the situation.
Apart from a factor
of two that we
have gamma, 2 gamma, and gamma.
The fact of 2 comes of course.
Are you asking what is the
spectrum of the electric field
or what is the
spectrum of the power?
If you go from e
to e squared, then
if you have an exponential
decay with gamma of e,
e squared decays with two gamma.
So that's where
factors of 2 come from.
AUDIENCE: Can you label the top
of the diagram with [INAUDIBLE]
just the delta equals 0.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Give me a second.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
g equals 0, right?
PROFESSOR: The
fact is here we're
looking at limiting cases.
And the more important
thing is that this
is the case of weak drive.
So what is more important is
that the drive frequency is 0.
I'm not giving you
the full picture here.
The full glorious
derivation is in API.
And just tried to
sort of entertain
you by giving you
a few appetizers.
If you want, read it up there.
But what I want to show you
is they're two simple cases,
but it looks already
intriguing because here this
is wider than the side bends,
and here it's the opposite.
And I want to give
you a taste of it.
And I'm not doing it
rigorously, and you're right,
I have to think about it.
But the important part is
that the drive frequency is 0.
We are not driving, we
are not rotating in x.
The system is mainly
rotating around the z-axis.
And at that moment, the matrix
for the differential equation
for the optical Bloch vector
has three imaginary parts.
It's gamma, 2 gamma,
and gamma or half of it
if you look at the amplitude.
And now I want to just
show you in a second how
we can get the second part.
But yeah, I'm guilty as charged.
There are small
gaps in my argument.
But all I want to
show you is how
you find-- I want to
just sort of convince you
that the optical Bloch
equations with this matrix
have all the ingredients
to explain it.
OK, so what I've done
here is I've shown you
that we have those
three ingredients.
And actually the moment--
I should have said it
before answering your question.
When we now crank up delta,
what we're physically doing
is we're doing a rapid
rotation of the Bloch vector
around the z-axis.
So when we rapidly
around the z-axis,
we're not doing anything
to the z component,
but we're strongly mixing
the x and y component,
but since [? half ?]
the imaginary part--
I'm waving my hands now.
We're not changing the
imaginary part for x and y.
And we still have two imaginary
parts, which are gamma over 2.
One imaginary part
which is gamma.
I know I'm running out
of time, but I only
need a few more minutes.
So if you do a rapid
rotation around the z-axis,
we obtain three eigenvalues.
Since we rotate around the
z-axis, we have minus gamma.
Sorry, my notes are better
than what I remember.
I looked through the notes.
But what I wanted to
say was the following.
I first show you what
are the eigenvalues
of this matrix in one case,
which is just a warm up.
I'm telling you there
are those three values.
And now I'm saying
we are interested
in the physical situation
of rapid rotation.
The rapid rotation modifies
the three eigenvalues.
The three eigenvalues
are no longer real.
The rapid rotation
around the z-axis
adds an imaginary i delta
to the x and y-axis.
Because now we are rotating,
x and y are getting mixed.
And this means now that
we have three peaks.
They are located in the
rotating frame at 0.
This is the carrier
at plus minus delta.
These are the two side bends.
And this part are
the widths of it.
This is how you have to
interpret the result.
So we have to know three peaks.
And the full widths
of half maximum
for the intensity, which
is the amplitude squared
is gamma, 2 gamma, and gamma.
And we can now immediately
proceed to the next case.
If we are on resonance, and
we drive The system strongly,
now we are driving the
system strongly around,
not the z-axis,
around the x-axis.
So now if we add the strong
drive around the x-axis,
we have now eigenvalues
which is plus minus ig.
This is the rotation
we add, and this
gives e to the
i-- in rotation ge
to the i omega t gives an ig.
And what happens
is the following.
The rapid rotation
around the x-axis-- well,
if you rotate around the
x-axis, you're not touching x.
And without any rotation,
we had an eigenvalue
for x which was
minus gamma over 2.
And if you take the matrix
of whatever the system
and rotate it around the
x-axis, this is preserved.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
PROFESSOR: Yep, I
need one more minute.
Sorry.
But the rotation around
x strongly mixes y and z.
So therefore the two
other eigenvalues
appear at rotation ig.
And it is now the average
of gamma and gamma over 2,
which is 3/4 gamma.
And if you go to the
amplitude squared, it is 3/2.
So therefore we
have the situation
that we have those
three eigenvalues.
And this is responsible
for the three peaks
at plus minus g and 0.
And the widths of it
is I have to multiply
by a factor of 2
gamma and 3/2 gamma.
And this explains the
two limiting cases
I presented to you earlier.
No time for question, the
other people are waiting.
Reminder we have
class on Friday.